premier volet de notre page d'été
consacrée à l'excellence à la française
nous sommes chez l'as des as yvon
cauchemar et par deux fois meilleur
ouvrier de france c'est le reportage que
nous vous proposons philippe roy laurent
blanc a absorbé par son ouvrage seul le
martèlement de sa massette rythme le
temps la concentration est extrême
elle traduit la maîtrise du geste c'est
ridicule oui car la pierre que je
travaille est une roche tendre
donc il faut à faire absolument
attention aux éclats extérieur lors de
l'exécution
c'est un travail de longue haleine
magnifiée par un signe de reconnaissance
la célèbre collerette bleu blanc rouge
qui distingue les meilleurs ouvriers de
france
ce métier il vous colle à la peau ah oui
tout à fait je suis à ma quatrième
génération de de marbrier de père en
fils
nous avions donc une marbrerie funéraire
et donc on est sorti donc cette
spécialité de graveur sur pierre
je pense que c'est peut-être de la
pierre qui coule dans mes veines sais
pas si on peut dire ça mais c'est un
métier
peut-être qu'ils peuvent paraître
basique mais la gravure ne s'arrête pas
à la lettre
il travaille aussi leur ornementation
les feuilles d'acanthe les choses de
minitieuse créative aussi pour des
certaines réalisations pour des clients
nous avons la notification du nombre
d'or le mot calligraphie et le nombre
d'or qui est de 1 618 avec quelques
outils qui ont servi à faire cette
réalisation artistes et artisans comme
il se définit yvan cochery est également
marbrier tailleur de pierre
graveur et peintre un artiste complet
vous avez plusieurs corde à votre arc
notamment la peinture c'est également
une source d'inspiration
absolument il est vrai que le fait de
travailler en l'occurrence la delà de
l'acrylique le mélange des couleurs
fonds représente une certaine forme de
guetter une façon de se libérer
également la du quotidien meilleur
ouvrier de france section graveur
ornemaniste sur pierre en 1986 yvon
cochery récidive en 1994 en décrochant
le titre très envié de meilleur ouvrier
de france section travaux marbrier un
parcours riche et dense après ce
reportage n'en retrouver notre invité
pour un entretien
histoire de mieux le connaître de mieux
le cerner par deux fois vous avez été
meilleur ouvrier de france certains
n'ont rêvé vous l'avez fait ça mérite
une explication
oui tout simplement j'ai sans doute la
chance dans nos métiers de la delapierre
d'avoir plusieurs possibilités de
s'exécuter et d'obtenir deux fois
justement même voire trois fois en
taille de pierre notamment le titre de
meilleur ouvrier de france tout à fait
que voit-on devant nous alors ça c'est
une pièce qui a été réalisé une pièce de
compagnonnage pour ma réception
compagnonnage égalitaire et donc la
représentation est un ruban le ruban de
noailles bus c'est à dire qu'il démarre
à un endroit et il revient au même
endroit ça c'est important
il a ensuite la forme du 8 et l'infini
et il s'intitule enfin je les intitulés
humanité car il nous représente et
représente toute l'humanité au travers
des gravures qui ont été exécutés je
reste avant tout un artisan parce que
l'artisan est quelqu'un qui travaille de
ses mains qui créent et qui module qui
transforme la matière donc c'est un tout
à la fois en quittant l'atelier du rez
de chaussée on retrouve à l'étagé la
salle d'exposition elle déborde de
formes et de couleurs avec un fil
conducteur
l'éternel féminin
il représente tellement de choses elle
présente la vie la maternité etc
donc je pense que c'est un élément est
un support de base pour un sculpteur qui
est quand même assez extraordinaire
comment vous allez travailler ce modèle
alors avec une base d'un modèle vivant
donc il m'a permis d'avancer de garder
surtout des bonnes proportions pour que
je puisse l'exploiter au maximum
j'ai le sentiment que vous avez aussi
gardé une âme d'enfant tout à fait
aztèque puisque je l'appelle aztèque
était simplement une mascotte qui me
représentais un petit peu ce côté drôle
avec son petit ventre et c'est à ses
yeux son creux mais ce qui n'empêche pas
d'avoir une expression tout à fait
sympathique au regard des autres
prochaine étape de notre périple
le dernier horloger du loir et cher